L
>>S
FOR Y OL
WITHIN, SOMEBODY
ORDING TO THWAY  THES,
TO WIN, DEMOCRATIC LEADING
OR FIRM,OF
OF RS IDENTIF
THATS
KE BETTER.
WHAT WOULD YOU SAY, YOU AD
IN
>> AN EXTRAORDINARY JOB,G
LT TIMES, I DON'T  ANY
KIND OY AT
A LOT R SELECTED, BERNIED RUN, ,
ATTENTION COPYROUGH A DIFF A ET
NFARILY AS A
BOTINANRISING AND SUPPLY
ES, IT H
GOTTEN MORE EXPEAND
, EEMUCH
ATTENTION TO THE
E AFGHAN
PL RATIS THAN EC
WILL ALLOW
TOTHOSE NT TE ENVBREAK THROYOU
COMFORTABLY.D ABLESSE  SYECY,
IRRITATED ME BUT OVERALL, I E G
AND THAT'S W TO
CONCLUDE ABOUT JOEEN AS
WELL. S
UKRAE, SAID DECRARION CALL,
DOESYOHTPRESERMOCRACY?
I I.
LEFT OFFE  SSTING, BEFOR
ANLOMADE RAI
EXTRAORDINARY ACHIEVEMENT OF
E EURONION
THATNENT T WAR,
FOR CENTUR NOW AND PEACEFUL AS Y
WAP EUROPETHE WESTERN MO  HISTO
THR MAS SMEOPLE OT INDEPENDENTLE
.
THEMSELVES, WITHUCBATHAT
REMINDED EUROPE OF WITH A WO BE
AD VERY H AND THEY S IDING,
MAD ANSUPPORT UKRAINE, I THAND V
STTO SEND A
MESSAGE TO SOMEBODY LIKE PUTIN,
ABLE TO WILLY-NILLY DETERMINE E.
>> HS THING,
20 GREAT THING, CE WHILE YOU'RE
OFFICE PUTIN THE
ANNEXATION OF CRIMEA, MANY
ENOUGH REDLINES OU ND THAOR THL
WHAT IS YOURCT
AND I WANTO D, AND COLLEAGUE,
UNDER SIO ICISM,THERE HAVE LMAD
RU
THAT
>> THE UKRAINE OF TE AREAL T
NOT AN
IN OCRBE WAS FULL OF LOTN SPEAKT
TIAMENT AT TIME STILL F
MPATHI
AND THIDE  M
PA HPEBUT ALSO
GIVE ENORMS O N
TH EUROPEANS KICKING
TOTHE NCTIONS WE DIDRENTIR PRUDR
THROUGH THBASS INTO RI--ESOF UKN
EUROPEAN MINDSET WASTHE
TI, WE
AND PARTWHAT HAPPED, WAS
SEPE OM RUSSIA,
N TOSTAND
TO PRE BOTMILY AND
CIVIC LEAGUE, AND TO RESIS
THE WAY  OE REASONS WHY THEY
WH IN AT LEA
INCREDIBLY MISGU, NOT TO
GAL AND INCREDIB